the time to change is here because the
coronavirus brought more than chaos and
fear all great changes are preceded by
chaos we have all had our share of loss
it is time for the world to change the
virus also brought us a new perspective
it took us out of the crazy rat race
that made us so aggressive it gave
nature time to rest and heal from our
mess we are our worst enemy I guess but
it is time for the world to change if
not right now than when it is time to
stand up all your good men to show the
world how to really live that it is
better not to always take but to give
yes we humans have a dark selfish nature
and it causes all kinds of anger but it
is time to change the virus sent us all
home to our families and into our rooms
on our knees for too long have people
eat at the earth and now it is time for
a rebirth for too long we have focused
on money falsely believing that it will
make us free the virus took us into
lockdown before we all had a breakdown
it is time to change it it's time to
renew your mind if you don't you will
forever stay blind
what is your purpose in this life do you
ever think about the afterlife there
comes a time when your life will end
where will your soul then be sent it is
time to change time to get your
priorities straight your friends and
family wait